so tell us about this dish you're going
to teach us from your upcoming book so
this is in the winter chapter it's a
wild mushroom bolognese
and we got to start already so in this
pot we have some bacon we got some
onions caramelizing it with a little bit
of salt and some carrots and they're
softened and ready to go and right now
we're ready to add in some freshly
minced garlic uh-huh and then we're
gonna add our mushrooms in we have some
really nicely chopped portabella and
oyster mushrooms the nice thing with
this recipe is you can use so many
varieties because they all have
wonderful unique flavors we're stirring
this in and the mushrooms are going to
cook down a bit they're going to have
more flavor and a lot of the water is
going to get cooked off as well
and then once these cook down
we're going to add
some
delicious tomato paste tomato paste so
we have umami on umami yes and like
tomato paste is such a wonderful
ingredient you really take
all the nutrients all the flavor out of
the tomato and just concentrate it with
sunlight you know and here we can add in
like a nice pinch of salt
so
here everything's coated it's smelling
delicious like i love these like just
wonderful smells and you have some
choices for deglaze in the pan and
adding some liquid back this is where i
get intimidated but i do want to call
something out about your recipe that i
went through last night
so
i get nervous when i hear deglaze the
pan and get the brown bits this is where
my stomach churns and i feel very
inadequate in the kitchen do i pour the
whole thing in yeah you can put the
whole thing in we have two different
pieces here some studio magic happening
here
because we have our
simmered away
delicious look at the difference in
color you could just see it really
cooked down it's like a gravy yes oh my
gosh beautiful we also have some
delicious hand-cut pasta in front of us
and
you can make it you could buy it i think
it's fun to make so it's like a fun
thing to do with your kids too but i
understand time so go ahead and just can
i just ladle it in there so that i kind
of coat the noodles we're going to ladle
some in and coat the noodles just to
give them a start okay this is oh my god
this is so exciting
i don't know why it's pasta for me it's
just my very favorite food there's
something about it that's so artistic so
comforting so
incredibly
expressive and diverse it can be so many
things
yeah
i oh you have the perfect twirl i do
yeah i love this here i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring it closer so you can just
open this oh you know what's the best
trick yes sorry take your ladle
actually put it on there and then start
to twirl you're also so brave for not
using any apron in this
i'm not using an apron
you get on there you get on there
beautiful
i think it's nice
[Applause]
so ladle some more of that sauce on it
and i did ladle some sauce on a little
extra sauce on top oh you son of a [ __ ]
sorry
you could grab some delicious parmesan
and just grate it on a parmigiano yes
sprinkle it over you could add some more
herbs whatever you love
okay cheers see your portions what i'd
really eat yeah this is like a um i was
just trying to be fancy
and ladle my way into a perfect little
thing
this is so exciting
oh my gosh
oh it is so wintery and delicious cozy
like hearty as like
absolutely roastingly delicious tomatoey
mushroom forward oh my gosh can you
write this
that wasn't about
i also really want to talk about
how beautiful it is the way you speak
and if we could all just be a little
more gentle with each other i'm sorry it
makes me emotional
people want to learn and they don't want
to learn by
that sort of fast-paced judgment they
want a gentleness and that's what you're
doing and i so appreciate that
you're doing it too
clearly you're a kindred spirit
[Applause]
i i i'm not having a nervous breakdown i
really just appreciate your approach and
i think it's a really masterful one and
i think food is love yeah coming
together it's having a dinner with your
family or friends and just taking a
breath and like putting your phone aside
so
let's speak that language kindly and
together
well you speak it so beautifully
anyway john canal thank you so much for
this profound tutorial
that really struck such a chord with me
i'm so grateful visit the drewberrymart
show.com in cookbook club to check out
john's pick for cookbook club for
himself i can't wait to see what that is
will you tell us
okay good go to.com to find that out and
the preppy kitchen recipes for seasonal
and simple pleasures
is available for pre-order and will be
available october 4th and we'll be right
back
[Music]
you